i'm going to kind of combine two questions because
i think they're similar um sister beverly has axed
on on zoom how does god judge between excuse me
how does god judge children who may die before
they understand right from wrong and i'm just
gonna access the second question so you could
see the connection which is from mark anthony
cromwell brother sherlock will my twin siblings
who died before birth be resurrected during the
second coming kind of similar but all i can tell
you is what god told moses when moses said i
believe let me pray again father as i continue
to answer questions from your beloved people
give me simple wisdom i pray in jesus name amen
in exodus 33 verse 11 the bible says this is moses
speaking and he said i beseech you show me thy
glory and he said i will make all my goodness pass
before thee and i will proclaim the name of the
lord before thee and i will be merciful to whom i
will be merciful i will show will be gracious to
whom i will be gracious and will show mercy unto
my will shall mercy god is a merciful god remember
he's not willing that and he should perish second
peter chapter three verse nine first timothy
chapter two verse four you will have all men to
be saved and to come unto the knowledge of the
truth so it's much more likely that god will do
something to save them than that he will let them
perish that's the limit of my wisdom based on the
fact that god does not like to see people perish
ezekiel 33 11 as i live saith the lord say unto
them say to them as i lift saith the lord i have
no pleasure in the death of the wicked god does
not like to see people lost calvary is proof of
that and so while i don't know precisely what
will happen to the twins who perish in the womb
or who died one month outside of the womb we serve
a god who prefers to save them to lose ultimately
amen amen and i thank you for mothers of little
babies who passed away it could be that what
happens to you may affect the baby it could
be but i don't want to speculate it's not safe
i will say we serve a merciful god who loves to
save and he does not punish people for ignorance
at the time of ignorance god went out amen
amen and i think that well that answers sister
beverly's question in terms of children
who may not understand right from wrong
god does not punish ignorance in fact
that hell fire his strange work yes yes
yes yes doesn't punish ignorance doesn't mean
he likes ignorance he doesn't like it either
that's why you constantly find particularly this
in the epistles to know to know to know i want
you to know i want it god wants us to know but
in genuine ignorance god is very compassionate
amen